DEPENDENCE ON CHINA.
CHINESE CONTROL OF THE UNITED
STATES.
WE HAVE A JOURNALIST THAT HAS
LOOKED CAREFULLY INTO THIS STORY
AND JOINS US TO EXPLAIN.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
STARTING WITH THE PREMISE THAT
IF YOU CONTROL A COUNTRY'S
ENERGY SUPPLY, YOU CONTROL THAT
COUNTRY.
WHERE IS THE UNITED STATES
MOVES?
>> WELL, OUR PROBLEM HERE IS
THAT EVERYTHING WITHIN OUR
ENERGY -- THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH TO HOW
WE FUEL OUR COUNTRY.
IT MAKES US RELIANT ON CHINA FOR
ALL OF THIS SOURCES OF ENERGY.
SO SAY FOR INSTANCE SOLAR
PANELS.
THEY ARE NOT MANUFACTURED AT
LEAST INTO A DEGREE THAT IS
NECESSARY IN THE UNITED STATES.
THEY'RE MAINLY MANUFACTURED IN
SOUTHEAST ASIA AND IN CHINA.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION RECENTLY PUT A
TARIFF ON THEM, SO ALL OF THESE
SOLAR PANELS THAT ARE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY JUST HAVE THE ROD
STICKING UP, THERE'S NO PANELS
BECAUSE WE COULDN'T GET THEM
FROM CHINA.
HE LIFTED THAT, HOWEVER, IT'S
GOING TO TAKE A YEAR OR TWO FOR
THOSE PANELS TO GET HERE.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE PANELS ARE
NOT ONLY ARE THEY MADE IN CHINA,
BUT EVEN IF WE MADE THEM HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES, WE NEED THE
RAW MINERALS FROM CHINA TO MAKE
THE PANELS.
WE'RE TOTALLY RELYING ON CHINA
TO MAKE OUR ENERGY SUSTAINABLE
UNDER THIS CLIMATE CHANGE
MANDATE.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
SO CHINESE TAKEOVER OF THE
UNITED STATES.
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE DON'T CALL
IT THAT.
GOIN